i've been hosting this podcast called
artificial intelligence for
over two years now and i'm finally ready
to release version
2.0 of the podcast with two updates
change podcast name to lex friedman
podcast
very creative and switch the video to
ascii
i may or may not be kidding about the
second part but
i'm just excited to have figured out
that employer and vlc have a bunch of
ascii video modes
including matrix view i can make a quick
video tutorial on that if people are
interested
anyway i decided to change the name to
just
lex friedman podcast for several reasons
first that's what most people call it
anyway
second i've already been interviewing
physicists historians philosophers
mathematicians writers athletes
switching away from ai in the name gives
me the freedom to do that a little bit
more
i still want to talk to the top
researchers in artificial intelligence
and
science and tech in general but also
people who inspire me and have
had a big impact on my life outside of
science and tech
third most practically i've found a
guest even slightly outside the field of
ai like
neuroscience neurobiology physics
chemistry math
have been intimidated by the name ai
so going with a silly generic name my
name
just uh seems easier hopefully you see
that i
try hard to make the guest the star of
the show not to take myself too
seriously
or seriously at all and always ask the
simplest possible questions in hopes of
arriving at something fundamental
and even beautiful even if it makes me
look like an idiot
which i very often am
rss feed is still the same everything is
still the same
if you enjoy this thing share it with
others your kind words
as before as always and your love
has been fuel for me for which i'm
forever grateful
version 3.0 will be outside the
simulation
but for now let us stay here a little
longer
love you all
you